When it comes to horror movies, you need a
great ending to truly make it epic.
A bad ending can ruin even the scariest of
spooky films, but a great horror movie ending
can stick with you long after you've left
the theaters.
Here are some truly epic horror movie endings.
Spoilers ahead.
Kill List
This story follows two hit men, Jay and Gal,
who are hired to murder three seemingly random
people.
Ultimately, their "kill list" leads them into
the English countryside where they're attacked
by a creepy cult.
Gal is murdered, and Jay is forced to battle
against a hooded, hunchbacked man.
Jay dispatches his opponent with relative
ease with several stabs to its back, but he's
shocked when the cloak is pulled back to reveal
his wife.
Worse still, the "hunchback's" bump is actually
their young son, strapped to his mom's back
as part of an occult ritual.
Absolutely stunned that he's just butchered
his family, Jay disappears into his own mind
as the cultists applaud the fight and place
a crown atop his head.
The Guest
The chaos begins when army veteran David visits
the family of a fallen comrade.
At first, David seems like a cool guy, but
under that charming, hunky exterior, there's
an ultra-aggressive super soldier waiting
to explode.
Several plot turns later, David is chasing
our sibling heroes, Anna and Luke, through
a high school haunted house, seemingly intent
on doing away with them.
Luckily, Luke gets the upper hand when he
stabs David in the chest.
The authorities soon arrive on the scene,
and it looks like Anna and Luke are finally
safe…until a familiar-looking fireman walks
out of the gym.
The Invitation
The story of this creepy film focuses on a
man named Will, who receives a dinner invitation
from his ex-wife Eden for a dinner party with
some old friends that he hasn't seen in years.
But beneath the polite conversation, Will
can sense there's something strange going
on, all while Eden and her new husband David
are promoting some bizarre cult.
As the evening wears on, Will notices David
walking into the backyard and lighting a red
lantern.
Soon after, Eden and David start butchering
every guest they can get their hands on.
Fortunately, Will survives the assault, but
as he steps outside, he sees something almost
as horrifying.
Nearly every house he can see is showing the
same red lantern that David lit earlier, implying
that his dinner party wasn't the only one
to have such a violent dessert.
Krampus
Fed up and frustrated with his unruly relatives,
a young boy named Max loses the Christmas
spirit, tears up his letter to Santa, and
tosses the shreds out the window.
Little does Max know he's just summoned a
horned beast named Krampus who plans on punishing
Max's entire family.
But after a heart to heart with the Christmas
demon, Max wakes up to find the whole invasion
was just a dream, and soon, he's peacefully
celebrating Christmas with his entire family.
However, Max finds a bell with the word "Krampus"
etched onto the side as his family also seems
to remember the horrible events of what Max
had thought was just some Christmas Eve nightmares.
In fact...it doesn't seem like the family
really escaped Krampus' wrath at all.
The Witch
In The Witch, William and his Puritan family
are banished to the wilderness because of
their super-extreme beliefs, and forced to
contend with the supernatural monster that
seems to be skulking around their new home.
"Peek...boo!"
The witch does a pretty good job of tearing
the family apart, and eventually, the only
member who isn't dead or missing is eldest
daughter Thomasin.
Left all alone in the middle of nowhere and
feeling cut off from the Almighty, Thomasin
strikes a deal with Satan.
"Wouldst thou like to live deliciously?"
"Yes."
Following Satan's orders, Thomasin strips
nude and wanders into the woods, where a coven
of witches rise into the air as Thomasin joins
them.
Shaun of the Dead
This horror-comedy isn't just full of laughs.
It also has some genuinely terrifying moments
and a few scenes that will leave you a bit
emotionally raw, too.
Honestly, Shaun of the Dead's climax seems
like one of the darkest moments Edgar Wright
has ever directed, as Shaun says goodbye to
his best friend Ed, who's been bitten by a
zombie.
"What are you talking about?"
"I’ll only hold you back."
"Yeah, but-"
But in the last scene of the film, Wright
sends the audience off with a bit of the ol'
switcheroo.
As it turns out, Shaun's life after the zombie
apocalypse really isn't all that different
from how it was before the zombie apocalypse.
“Ed!”